my daddy uh
[ __ ] when i was just a baby was in my
bottle you know what i'm saying
so
your dad was what
he was giving me whiskey
um jim bean no
moonshine
in my bottle
this is a baby yeah really
where'd you grow up
in mexico and kentucky
i hear a twang
what was your childhood like
i'm very violent
a lot of domestic violence my mother my
father
i got shot by my father when i was 15.
shot
i just well good shotgun by mistake or
no he tried to kill me and my mom
my mom was stupid enough she stayed with
him
not me when he shot me at 15 i got the
hell out of there
and i drink every day
it was kind of crazy
it was crazy
growing up
from the age my earliest memory i
remember was like four or five years old
my dad he was a big gang member
from mexico to united states
and he drank a lot and i drank a lot
more with him
from early age
and all he did was
beat on me beat my mom
i got 17 brothers
no sisters
two kids
i know that
17 brothers
you're the only girl among 18 kids
wow
yeah
did you finish high school
no
i didn't finish high school
um
lived on the street since i was
15
after my dad shot me
was there other stuff going on at home
other than being shot at a shotgun oh
yeah i was molested
by my dad oh your dad
yeah he um he raped me at the age of 10.
and
my mom suddenly said it was my fault
okay whatever [ __ ] you know
my fault
so
my brothers
very violent boys
i would always have to
be in the closet
chained up
a little bucket to piss some [ __ ] in
sometimes i get food sometimes i
wouldn't
then you start drinking
at an early age i remember my first
drink at five
but like on your own drink on my own oh
really
i went i remember i went and got my
dad's cool and my mom said there was
some water in there
and i went to get it and it was a bottle
of gin
and i started drinking it
you ever stopped
i haven't stopped since
i drink every day how do you know
47. is it good for 47.
okay
thank you but okay
where do you stay now
on the street you're on the streets down
here
it's rough down here for a woman right
oh
get by sometimes you know sometimes it's
hard
but this is a story of life you know
everything's not always easy
out here especially
um i've been raped by gangs
um
i've been beat up
i've been left for dead
but i always seem to get back up
and your drinking starts in the morning
how you see them soon as i open my eyes
um as soon as i open my eyes i've got to
have
my crystal and i've got to have a glass
of this again
and juice
and if i don't get it
oh man that's not good how much are you
drinking today
um
go over a feel
sometimes more
sometimes less
just depends on how my day goes yeah
now i drink beer too on top of it
so
how do you pay for it
prostitute
um
stealing bikes
whatever i gotta do
sometimes i have to
lay with old men and
you know
sleep with them and do sexual favors and
stuff
but it pays for my drinks yeah
when you were a young girl i mean i know
you started drinking early but
did you have dreams of doing something
with your life
other than what you're doing yeah
i used to dream about being a mute
musician
but then all that stopped are you a
musician
i used to be yeah what would you play
piano
you have kids
i have two you have two kids
one of them is not mine but she's mine
and i've been married since i was 16.
and
i've been separated since i was 19.
so so you're still married technically
yeah we're still married
he was very abusive as well
it seems like every time i even think
about a man it's got to be somebody
who's abusive
it's not
anybody good for me
do you think that's a result of having
the father that you had
probably
you know
17 brothers and a dad that was
17 brothers that are locking you in a
closet yeah and a dad that rapes you
so
yeah
what's your biggest regret
um
not finished in high school
and picking up a bottle
and quitting it quitting alcohol is not
just putting down the bottle and
quitting no
i've tried to quit on my own several
times
there's no way
but what's the first thing that starts
happening if you didn't get your drink
in the morning oh i start shaking i'm
i'm
throwing up
it's just
not good
then i'm tearing down my tent
turn everybody else's around round me up
you raised your kids
no no the state did
because of alcohol
because of alcohol
seems like no matter what i do i can't
get enough alcohol
it
it makes me feel nothing
i don't have to feel anything so yeah
that's why i think all these people down
here are doing drugs or alcohol or
whatever they're doing
to not feel but the alcohol it takes you
it's clean
you know it's not dirty like all this
other [ __ ] around here
it comes from a manufacturing you know
which drugs do too but
seagram's is more dependable more
reliable than that yeah yeah then you're
i don't have my gym
you know enjoy have my gin i just have
my
my beers
the mexican bar right here i i drink a
lot there you know as soon as i leave
here i'm going straight over there
you have any friends
i don't have friends
yeah how many years you've been in l.a
um
six
what brought you out here
just needed a change
i thought i thought i could come out
here and quit drinking
get my life together [ __ ] where were you
before l.a
um
arizona
what part of kentucky did you grow up in
um eastern kentucky
what part hazard
i've been to hazard 20 times really oh
yeah
i was born upon the mountains yeah house
is beautiful
yeah that's where all the moonshine is
yeah yes
that's my that's my stuff right there
eastern kentucky is one of the most
beautiful parts of the country yeah it
is
but it's also one of the most dangerous
parts people think la's dangerous
[Laughter]
yeah i know
no uh eastern kentucky is a place where
i could pull up in somebody's driveway
and just start getting shot at because
they're cooking meth or something like
that
you couldn't pull up on her farm
at all
my dad would be out there with ak-47
shooting up your vehicle whoever was in
it that map is kids or whatever yeah
i've heard that from a few people so you
can go to his house but if you pull up
in his driveway you can get shot at yeah
so
you know i remember first barrel of
moonshine i made
i was 12 years old
and my dad said no you got to make sure
that temperature is right victoria
i said whatever i know i've been
watching you for years
and uh
it blew up on me
oh so i wasn't mad that it blew up
like
you know the machine and stuff was down
i was mad because all the alcohol was
gone
you know
i was like
really upset about it
you drink moonshine
oh yeah white lightning i'll bring you
some really i'm not gonna drink it hell
yeah
i drink a [ __ ] man i got a bottle in my
kitchen
that stuff is a bomb
what do you uh what do you worry about
what are you afraid of
what i'm afraid of
[Music]
um
i'm afraid that i'll never quit drinking
i'm 47 now
a lot of people when they wake up in the
mornings they think about
what they're going to cook for breakfast
or just that mean
first thing on my mind's alcohol
alcohol and drugs
and then later sex or whatever you know
so
people
say that
an alcoholic is
the worst kind of
drug act or whatever
i'd rather have my alcohol than anything
you know because it completes me
it makes me who i am
[Music]
makes me feel whole i guess i'm scared
of not feeling whole
you know not feeling complete
you think you're lonely
lonely
i'm lonely but i don't trust anyone so
it's not gonna change
well
can you imagine if you had grown up in a
different
environment different family
where your dad wasn't doing that stuff
to you and your brothers weren't abusing
you and stuff like that
but your life would have turned out like
many times
i've thought about
where i'd be
what i would be doing
um
what companies would i own because
i was always smart growing up
business-wise
and
but
i let alcohol consume me so
and now it's a
it's a
medicine for
an eternal illness
you know
what my dad did to me was he took away
everything that i had
as a child
as a woman as i got older
him and my uncle both
my mother's brother they both raped me
together
and
thought it was okay
they would pour alcohol on me
and
just you know rape me and that's not the
other
thought it was okay like the next day
wasn't nothing
you know
it wasn't okay
just you and your mom against all those
boys
my mom she didn't care she said drunk
too
she said drunk from time she woke up
time to pass out
i'd be responsible even if
even if i was drinking i had to cook for
everybody
i had to clean
wash clothes
i'd do everything
take care of the babies
you know my mom she didn't care
all she cared about was getting that
next strength right next
time you know
she would um
she said
vicky you go take care of this
you know
and i'd be like
mom i have practice after school i can't
now [ __ ] that practice you go take care
of these kids today
so that's what i did
i took care of the kids and
until i was on
after my dad shot me and i got out
and then whatever they taught me as a
kid growing up that's what i use out of
here on the streets
wow
what was the best time of your life
when i was pregnant with my daughter
feeling life inside of me
a kind of life that nobody else can take
from you because you feel that
that love
after the baby's born
and
yeah that was the best time in my life
almost every woman i ask
gives me the same answer
like when they when they're with their
kids
kids are
now
i don't know if i can handle it
i'm older now
but
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
important lesson most important lesson
i've learned in my life
that would be
learning and knowing who i really am
and standing on it
that's that's the lesson i learned it's
a good one
all right victoria thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome i wish
you the best of luck
and uh
he's hype out there
i'll leave the streets are crazy
you